I still don't think Trump is going to be
the nominee though I wouldn't put money
on it I've put many stake bets on it
that may be a mistake I have a feeling
I'm jinxing going to be the nominee and
in what way yeah yeah the well I wrote
about this it's on my subsag it was
about two months ago because I
remembered this I looked back and saw
who was leading um who was the um the
polls for the pre Republicans nominee
for like 20 years it was never the guy
who turned out to be the nominee a year
before the election it's always
um name recognition so you know we can
go visit the Rudy Giuliani Presidential
Museum after this or the new Gingrich
Presidential Museum or the Fred Thompson
Presidential Museum or the Huckabee
Huckabee litty Dole lyy Dole was neck
and neck with bush litty Dole why
because she was the wife of the guy who
had just run for president it's all name
recognition we've never had somebody
with so much name recognition as Donald
Trump